Michael knows hosts the Michael Knowles
show and he joins me now Michael always
great to have you here good to see you
alright so let's start with the nickname
what I know it's dated what do you think
smart move bad move turn on turn off to
voters what do you make of it what Pete
worried I think this is the king of
branding striking again it's a brutal
nickname primarily because it's so funny
and it's so visual when you see those
two together you cannot help but laugh
it is a dated reference Pete Buddha
judge was right he responded and
probably the best way that he could
which is to say I've never heard of it
and you're an old man or something like
that I was always a Mad Magazine fan as
a kid most Millennials probably won't
get the reference but it who cares
Donald Trump is the President of the
United States now that he has said it
everyone gets the reference and the
reason that we're all still talking
about it is because it's a very accurate
comparison most people hadn't thought
about it before
and unlike Alfred enum and I think Pete
Buddha judge should worry you know
Michael since Buddha judge entered the
scene one person who's been having some
trouble is beta or or which is why beta
was now planning a reintroduction as
2020 buzzes around I want to get to this
ap headline beta of Warplanes
reintroduction as 2020 buzz fizzles okay
so is this gonna work do you have a shot
to come out of the gate kind of flub it
a bit and then say oh hold on a second
I'm gonna reintroduce myself to the
world maybe stop standing on counter
tops in my shoes maybe some new tactics
is this kind of work or is he done I'm
sorry that named beta or work it's just
not ringing a bell as he's that guy
maybe lost in Texas I Pete Budaj edge is
absolutely eating his lunch and the
reason for that is that Buddha judge is
in every way the better version of beta
O'Rourke
he is smarter he's better educated he's
more likable he's got executive
experience and he can check off another
box on the intersectional victimhood
pyramid he's just much better than beta
and so beta has fizzled away the best
chance that bado has now is to convince
Iowa voters that he has a legitimate
chance of bringing those electoral votes
from Texas over in a general election
it's a hard case to make it's a distant
case to make I think they know probably
is not
coming back now what about Acacio cortez
you know she's very passionate on social
media she appeals to young voters a lot
there's been a lot of talk of a
potential for her to endorse either
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren take
a listen to what she said and I want to
get your reaction what I would like to
see in a presidential candidate is one
that has a coherent worldview and logic
from which all these policy proposals
are coming forward I think senator
Sanders has that I also think senator
Warren has that you think you will
endorse during the Democratic primaries
I'm entertaining but it's not gonna be
for a while now could be great in a
primary but what about a new general
election if you have a OCS endorsement
good or bad the video that you weren't
showing is Bernie and Liz Warren saying
no please whatever you do don't endorse
us I wouldn't wish an AOC endorsement on
my worst enemy it's true that we all
can't help but talk about her and read
about her but when you look at the
actual polling in the state of New York
you know AOC zone home state left of
Lenin she is less popular than Donald
Trump it would be very difficult for her
so I'm hoping that she endorses Bernie
Sanders because Liz Warren appears to be
basically out of this race she's barely
registering in polls obviously that
could change but I wouldn't bet on it
Bernie Sanders does stand a legitimate
chance in this primary and therefore he
stands a legitimate chance in the
general election
so come on AOC go for it Doris Bernie
please you never know what the voter you
know the social media is powerful now
though those young voters really really
like her so someone like Sanders may be
saying you know what maybe I hook into
those young voters really well with an
IOC you never know Michael but things
are being here actually well with
Millennials she does she does when she's
on the air the snapchat the Instagram
all that stuff so thanks so much for
being here really appreciate it and
we'll obviously have more for you when
you see you again soon